100 years ago today November 18th 1915
Albert Einstein is again preparing to
lecture to the Prussian Academy and his
his mood is ecstatic because a few days
earlier he had used the equations that
he'd been developing for general
relativity to explain a long-standing
puzzle to do the motion of mercury he
had explained why Mercury's orbit shifts
a little bit each year nobody had been
able to do that finally Einstein
succeeds so his frame of mind is
absolutely triumphant but that morning
as he's preparing his lecture he also
opens the mail and in the mail he
receives a paper from David Hilbert and
this paper completely shatters
Einstein's triumphant mood because
remember a few days earlier David
Hilbert had written Einstein a postcard
where he says to Einstein I have figured
general relativity out and come visit
with me and I'll explain the solution to
you of course
Einstein says little busy not feeling so
well I'm not going to come visit you at
all but Einstein is completely rattled
by this and of course by receiving the
paper Hilbert basically said to Hein
Stein I will not take no for an answer
here is my work so Einstein reads the
paper and he sees within it ideas that
he's already been developing so he
immediately writes the hilbert and says
nothing really new here I've already
been down this trajectory you're not
telling me anything I don't already know
but it of course completely shakes
Einstein up as he realizes that Hilbert
is right on his tail toward realizing
the general theory of relativity so
Einstein he gains his composure he gives
his lecture on the motion of mercury and
then he turns to a final push to
complete the
of the general theory of relativity but
you have to bear in mind the context in
Stein's personal life at this moment is
really in chaos his estranged wife
maleva has left Berlin moved back to
Zurich taken the two kids with her I'm
Stein feels that his sons are turning
away from him and on top of that his new
love interest Elsa is also his cousin
she is putting tremendous pressure on
Einstein to finalize a divorce with
maleva
so he's working in Berlin in basically
an empty apartment with all of this
chaos in his personal life around him
and somehow he's able to push through
and as we will see next week come up
with the final form of the equations of
the general theory of relativity